dann auf einmal kommt felix so zu mir
und mainz jojo wir müssen hier weg da
werden zuschauer irgendwie zerquetscht
servus skills und herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen runde minecraft spielen des
3d games 24 er auf die in der guck mal
ob ich einen zweiten games noch
irgendwas kann ich glaube er nicht
aber hey und ich erzähle euch heute mal
einiges über die video days wie ich die
erlebt hat die bio das ist meine
perspektive denn das einiges passiert
also einige kranke sachen einige coole
sachen aber ihr werdet selbst sehen ich
war einfach gerade noch mal eine chance
bekommt
unter anderem wurden dann auf bayer und
kontrollierten autogrammstunden leute
verletzt und keine ahnung ich erzähle
euch einfach mal gleich aber als
allererstes in chronologischer
reihenfolge also zeit nicht korrekt
fangen wir mit unserer anreise anwesende
aus dem urlaub zurück gefahren
vier stunden um in köln sein zu können
bei dem video days.com sind am abend des
welche war das eigentlich am abend des 6
wenn sie mir glaube ich angekommen
genau am abend des 6 so haben uns dann
david duval getroffen der coole weise
auch im gleichen abend angekommen ist
sind dann noch bisschen rum gezogen in
köln und haben uns dann noch in eine
kita war begeben die kennt ihr sicher
diese kita soll es wirklich aufpasst mit
der es regel mit nein
ja haben da ein bisschen gestern abend
waren dann nichts wildes mehr gemacht
oder am nächsten tag gab es nämlich dann
die autogrammstunde gegen gott sei dank
erst um 12 uhr los
ja wenn sie mal hingefahren und was ganz
cool war ich weiß nicht ihr kennt
vielleicht diesen area control bereich
also ich war davor noch nie aber als ich
da rein gekommen wäre sagt den kennst du
doch irgendwoher hatte ich einfach dann
glaube ich irgendwie doch von dna oder
so mal gesehen und dadurch kann mit
dieser bereich durch die vertraut vor ja
dann dieses jahr durfte ich dann da
selbst durch steppen haben unsere
bändchen abgeholt haben wir unsere
autogrammstunden gegeben und das hat
mich echt überrascht dass die
autogrammstunden so gut besucht waren
also wir hatten richtige richtig richtig
lange schlange was natürlich
größtenteils an den anderen lag da ich
mir gar nichts vormachen
aber ich habe mich trotzdem gefreut dass
so viele leute
bei mir irgendwie auch bei mir
vorbeikommen und autogramme wollten ein
autogramm gefragt haben dass er mich
echt überrascht
also wir saßen da vier stunden 2 es war
geplant vier stunden zwei am vormittag
und zwei am nachmittag aber vorrichtung
von 12 bis 14 und dann von 16 bis 18 uhr
wird so ganz ganz grob geschätzt ich
weiß es nicht mehr sicher aber wir haben
alle vier stunden tatsächlich durch
geschrieben vor allen dingen bei mir hat
mich das wie gesagt überrascht so also
wie gesagt matschiner hätte nicht so
riesig groß aber dass ich dann vier
stunden autogramme gebe sicher werden
auch ein paar gesagt ja ich kenne zwar
nicht aber ich hole mal autogrammen oder
so da die eltern der von jedem
autogramme gesammelt und die kennen doch
niemanden
das heißt die eltern haben wir auch
keine ahnung ob ihr kind jetzt mich
schaut oder luca schaut oder felix genn
als fix dann bin ich da präfix meisten
seht ist ein ok hat irgendwas gutes
gehabt irgendwie nichts gefühlt hat doch
in schermbeck der könnte sehr wichtig
werden die nie war mit denn ihr wisst
ihr diaz regel wenn man voll und ohne
zählen hermann zieht also mit eisen oder
goldhelm dann muss man fünf liegestütze
machen hab ich kein bock drauf denn ich
wollte morgen schon trainieren aber das
ist eine andere sache
sodann kann mir autogramme dann am abend
gab es eine afterparty pipapo die wahl
nicht ganz nice weil die partys köln
diesmal nicht sogar waren wie köln
letztes jahr und können letztlich gar
nicht dabei sehr schön aber berlin
dieses jahr war deutlich besser von den
affen polizeilich gefühl aber das ist
eine andere sache dass man das
nebensächlich ist ja am nächsten tag
sind wir dann noch mal auf die video
days klar man hat auch mega viele leute
getroffen als er zu jona lena also weil
des stroms und so sehr viele leute aber
am zweiten tag war hat man keine
autogrammstunde mehr dass im wald suchen
gelaufen oder halt wissen darum gegangen
da in diesem den katakomben unter der
lanxess arena so war dass er mich an und
in der lanxess arena katakomben darf man
sich nicht die ganze zeit aufgehalten
und irgendwann als gedacht hey you wie
fühlt sich das ganz anders an als bei
den letzten
video days läuft irgendwas schief und
dann sind wir draufgekommen dass es
daran liegt dass er die ganze zeit
unterirdisch in diesem tunnel waren
wenn man sich nur andere youtuber
gesehen und so aber keine zuschauern
dann haben uns gedacht okay und stellt
noch mal raus müsse jetzt aussehen lola
junge er ist einfach nur nett wie bitter
für ihn ja dann sind wir ein bisschen
rum gesteppten dann kam auch wieder
dieses video days feeling also man
trifft zuschauer unterhält sich mit
denen ich habe ich mich mit wirklich
vielen zuschauern recht ausgiebig
unterhalten
das habe ich mich echt gefreut zu
sortieren hier sagt die frau nicht
wohlfeil kraft ohne grafite wird schwer
ein bisschen schwertner
der neue text effekt ist er 3d mit dem
spiel seit jahren fährt er spielt erst
seit ein paar tagen gut haben wir jetzt
nicht ich ziehe den schon mal rein in
gold apple ja okay wie den kümmert sich
an
und genau an diesem tag ist es eben auch
passiert im zweiten video des tag dass
wir dann irgendwann raus gegangen sind
und dann so richtig belagert wurde kam
so mega viele zuschauer
ich habe männer mit justin kurz
weggegangen weil ein bisschen ruhe
brauchen und dann auf einmal kommt felix
so zu mir um 1 jo jo wir müssen hier weg
da werden zuschauer irgendwie
zerquetscht und ich kann gar nicht mehr
gleich wusste gar nicht was abgeht und
habe gesagt ja okay gut dann machen wir
das haben uns dann sowieso sich am arm
genommen wie kleine kinder und sind dann
da weggelaufen weil felix einfach gar
nicht mehr klar kam der war richtig
fertig und dann sie sind weggerannt weil
wohl da wir standen vor der lanxess
arena sie längst arena ist ja so ein
oval ja das kennt ihr vielleicht und da
außen rum ist und regen auf gewissen
teil ist dann hinter diesen bringen
nochmal gebäude und dann standen wir an
diesem gebäude vor der lanxess arena an
der wand und luca max felix haben da
autogramm gegeben und die leute haben
sich so eine ewige schlagen sollen
traube mir gebildet und scheinbar wurden
da irgendwie gegen die kleine mädchen
irgendwie zertrampelt mal soviel voll
fertig
und dann abgehauen dann wirklich zum
taxi garanten das war schon ein bisschen
so real
ich weiß auch gar nicht wie ich das
kommentieren soll normalerweise sei es
bei sowas immer macht macht dies ich
mache das nicht das sollte die
quintessenz daraus seien aber keine
ahnung das war einfach komisch
hier könnt ihr mal die kommentare
schreiben was ihr davon haltet oder was
eure gedanken dazu sind also zwar
wirklich schon heavy ja weil ich einfach
mal gesagt haben ciao